in honor of juneteenth this sunday we
continue to highlight grassroots efforts
to reclaim african-american burial
grounds we've been following our friend
and former producer howard university's
own rodney hawkins and his family and
their efforts to recover their ancestral
cemetery in east texas well the family
recently returned for an annual cleanup
and this morning hawkins introduces us
to a woman trying to get recognition for
one of the largest african-american
burial grounds in the country
from the stately buildings to the
centuries-old cemeteries history is on
full display in richmond virginia except
here
beneath this highway under this
abandoned gas station and overgrown lawn
is one of the largest african american
cemeteries in the country shaco hill
african bearing ground but you couldn't
tell these people have been forgotten
they've been made invisible
and they're being treated as if they
never existed at all lenora mcqueen is a
genealogist who traced her great great
great great grandmother's grave to this
site no marble tells where kitty carrie
sleeps
only a simple slab of painted pine using
documents like this poem from 1866 where
kitty carey lived and died a slave over
22 thousand free and enslaved african
americans were buried here starting in
1816. this graveyard expanded to 31
acres when you drive past
22 thousand people are buried here when
they drive down this street they're
driving over it they re-extend the
street in about
1883
and bones and bodies it's in the city
council records bones and bodies are
used as fill in the street and left
sticking out of the ground that has to
hurt it does very much
it's appalling it took you years to find
your ancestor and to end that search
with this
yes
i'm sorry
it was horribly gut-wrenching
if i didn't laugh about it i would cry
next to the african burial ground sit
two nationally registered cemeteries for
the jewish and white communities
officially marked and well maintained
it's a stark contrast this isn't by
accident the white authorities during
jim crow segregation didn't have any
interest
in african-american graves mcqueen
turned to ryan smith history professor
and author for help there was also an
effort to build up the history of the
confederacy just as the bridge behind us
was being built in the late 1880s the
foundations for the robert e lee
monument were being set how do we use
history to change a nation to make us
better lonnie bunch is secretary of the
smithsonian institution why are
african-american burial grounds so
important not just to african americans
but to american history
you can tell a great deal about a nation
by what it remembers by what it
celebrates in its museums by what it
builds monuments to
and often what is neglected is
african-american and especially
african-american cemeteries he is
pushing for legislation to create a
national registry for african-american
burial grounds i think this register
could make connections could make allow
people to know their history better and
to honor that history by remembering
i know the power of these connections
firsthand one year ago our efforts to
restore my family cemetery allowed
researchers to identify my enslaved
great great great grandfather
despite this being
a document that shows my
ancestor as an asset
it still documents that he existed
you realize that
you are
not isolated you're from tradition
families and that should give you
inspiration as you live your own life
for most of her life she was enslaved on
the mormon plantation inspired by her
ancestor mcqueen has been pushing for
years to get recognition for the shaco
hill african burying ground starting
with a historic marker the graveyard has
been added to the state landmarks
register how does it feel to come this
far
it's kind of bittersweet because i know
there's still a long way to go this
place is still very much threatened the
national register is next on her list
her goal is to honor her ancestor and
others buried here so they may truly
rest in peace what do you think your
ancestor
would say to you it's about time for cbs
mornings rodney hawkins richmond
virginia it's about time what took you
so long
yeah i commend her for efforts oh
absolutely i was having a conversation
about this very thing priorities
and where do you place your priorities
in terms of who you honor and who you
respect and this is a brilliant example
of it if our history isn't preserved
properly it could fade into obscurity
absolutely this is a case where she has
done her job to help preserve our tell
your story let's tell your story